so the interesting thing is
the the relationship dynamics are
changing so dramatically now that
femininity is sort of being washed away
we have this story that we've talked
about quite a bit actually i mean we've
done multiple segments on but i want to
bring it up so that we can talk about
with you dr chloe the new york post
writes women are struggling to find men
who make as much money as they do
and so they talk about these women uh
who are like you know 30 year old who's
38 year old making 50 000 a year or
something and she can't find a man and
you know when i first talked about this
boy did every feminist lose their mind
they were like tim paul how dare you and
i said here's my assessment
if you're a 38 year old man
and you're making 50 000 a year
why would you want to date a 38 year old
woman who's making 50 000 a year when
you can date a 28 year old woman who's
making less and you can provide and
actually feel uh appreciated
cr like
it's it's this older guy
he's going to date a younger woman
because he has the money to do so it
feels good for him because she
appreciates what he's able to give to
her and he feels like he's able to give
something but dating a woman of the same
age he's not offering anything it
doesn't feel good and why would she want
to date someone who's not a provider so
ultimately what ends up happening is
guys like dating younger women so older
women who are career women are going to
have a harder time
yes they do they do i mean i can just
from my own practice you know it's it's
a difficult thing you know and and women
i'm not saying just to be against women
i'm actually really seeing it in
sympathy with women that women who who
do get older will say that it becomes
harder and harder for them to date yeah
because for a variety of reasons whether
it's um the fact that more of their age
peers are married or that maybe their
age peers are hoping to have kids and so
they're trying to date a younger woman
so that they have time to do that you
know i think that's why a lot of women
are freezing their eggs i i think women
would um
they need to pay attention to the
leonardo dicaprio principle
but i mean i know i know what you're
talking about would you want to explain
what leonardo dicaprio does leonardo
dicaprio regardless of his age dates
women who are in the early 20s and only
up to a certain age and then like every
woman's like 25 and then he breaks up
with her than 25. so here's my point
where are you saying i don't i saw a
headline it was like this is on twitter
it's pretty funny it's like leonardo
dicaprio's exes where are they now and
the top reply was probably in their late
20s
that's great so here's why i say this
25 year old man
he's going to date a 22 year old woman
35 year old man he's going to date a 22
year old woman 45 year old man he's
going to date a 22 year old woman you
see these these old men you know and
they're like 70 and they're wealthy and
they're dating 20 year old women
so as women get older
no matter what they could provide it's
let's say you're 40 and you don't make
that much money and you're hoping to
find something maybe maybe you'll find
someone older because they want younger
the the rich guy can still get the 20
year old woman and i'm not saying it
should be that way but the reality is if
a man at no matter what age i mean we've
seen 80 year old men with 20 something
year old women like you're robbing the
cradle and it's like i don't care i'm
old and i'm going to die and she's like
and then he doesn't i get his money
they like it
so the problem there is there's a
certain point for women where
no matter how old the guy is if he has
resources he will go for the 20 30 year
old woman
right and you know it kind of takes me
back to the article that you mentioned
when we started the poll showing that
you know younger uh men thought feminism
had done more harm than good but that
that was less true of a belief for for
young women to have and i couldn't help
but think about the fact that yeah
that's that's young women that that
they're currently saying oh yeah the
world is just telling me that i can have
it all i can do this i can do that and
everything else why wouldn't they like
that message right but when we start
talking about the older women who are
then saying yeah okay so i spent my 20s
climbing the career ladder and not
having kids and how is this feminism
really necessarily helped me so much i
would be curious about women you know
that are in their 30s for that poll the
interesting thing about all of these
polls
that take a look at feminism and dating
and stuff is that they don't understand
the difference in generations so when
they say did you know that women on
average make 17 or you know 23 percent
less than men it's like are you talking
about all age groups or are you
factoring in only gen x and below
because if you do that then all of a
sudden you realize women make more than
men
the problem is it's very simple in the
60s and 70s women didn't work the same
jobs as men they didn't make as much
money now they're they're they're
growing up
there is a disparity in the boomer
generation there was a disparity in the
silent generation the disparity is
mostly going away but the narrative
persists i mean the narrative of the pay
gap is wrong for a million one reasons
but what's happened now it's inverted
young women are more likely to graduate
college more likely to go to college
more more likely to get higher paying
jobs than their male counterparts but
because we lump in boomers with
millennials in the same stats it
presents this narrative a female
victimhood when boomers are long gone it
is going to be inverted and women will
make more than men well also it's
interesting that it's considered
victimhood right because what is
necessarily wrong with women choosing
not to work as much or choosing to work
fewer hours or just choosing not to work
at all because they want to have a
family why is that seen as like some
horrible form of oppression when they're
making that choice for themselves you
know feminists will often make the
argument that they just want women to be
able to make their own choices they're
not here to try to force a specific
social order under the greater whole
under the greater whole of society but
all of the decisions women make that
they complain about happen to be the
more traditional ones so it's clear that
they're not interested in letting women
make their own choices they have a
specific set of of standards they think
women should be living by for them
who's they that said that feminists i
mean that's feminism every single time
they complain about a disparity between
men and women it's a disparity uh which
is an indicator that women are behaving
more traditionally or taking on a more
traditionally feminine gender role you
know i think it is i think it is
social pressures
beget social pressures
i think that there was a genuine issue
with with equal opportunity women
complained about it so then people said
let's do a big pr campaign and tell
women they can be equal this created
social pressure among women to be those
fighting for equality because that was
the social cause
the social cause is speeding up it's
going faster and faster this is why i
think young men don't like modern
feminism because women are chasing
i shouldn't say women necessarily but
the the feminine is chasing after social
acceptance in a rapid degree regardless
of what that outcome is it's also
financial gives you uh like an air of
independence because if a man and woman
were dating and the girl the guy has all
the money he's got a job she doesn't and
she's like i want to eat a rabbit
tonight and the guy's like well i'm
paying for it so we're eating pizza but
i think the problem is not that she
doesn't have money the problem is she's
dating an [ __ ] if that's the case
maybe but after then
they're like okay let's get married and
it can be our money and the guy's like
you know what i'm the one making our
money so we're eating pizza
the point i'm trying to make is that
women feel pressured to do things
they're seeing on social media or in the
news because they think that's what they
have to do to be accepted to be
acceptable so they're adopting certain
behaviors they're uh putting on certain
messages they're holding up certain
signs because they all just chase after
each other's message well there's no one
to tell them like hey that's too much
women and girls are more vulnerable to
what's called social contagion right so
that's why like for example like in the
80s like it seemed like every woman like
had an eating disorder you know like
there's just certain things that can
suddenly crop up right and i think that
sometimes that can happen for for women
and girls as well when we get bombarded
with this messaging you know that we're
supposed to you know do certain things
in in career and that we can't even talk
about you know wanting something
different like from the psychology side
also
uh psychology studies have shown that
people on the left are
more collectivist and people on the
right politically tend to be more
individualist right and so one of the
both both sides have their extremes
which can be you know not so good but
when it comes to collectivism
one of the things that can happen is
that you can get attached to the
narrative of the group right and there's
you know group think to the point where
you don't even feel comfortable stepping
out of the narrative that's why it does
feel so insanely controversial for young
women to say you know i i'm not sure
that i i want to be a partner at a law
firm you know
yeah that's a very good point you know
you made this point earlier where you
said you'd be curious to know how women
would respond to being asked the
question of whether feminism was a net
positive once they're in their 30s or
older i think another thing we have to
consider is whether we should just be
asking women about the specific results
of feminism and asking them whether
they're happy with that because if you
just use the term oftentimes i think
what people are going to do is look at
what they think that movement intends
and not necessarily what its results are
so if you ask women questions like are
you happy with the fact that it's more
difficult for you to find a man who
makes as much money as you are you happy
with the fact that it's harder for you
to start a family i mean almost all of
them would say no
i thought chloe what you said about the
left being more collectivist the right
being more individualist or independent
i guess individualist the extreme of the
right individualism would be like what i
was saying earlier the guy and the girl
are in a relationship the guy makes more
money and he's like so he i'm going to
decide what we do because i'm the one
bringing the money and the money is
what's going to get the thing and that's
like the the ex so that's the the
extreme of the individualism that's
that's i disagree well i don't
necessarily disagree i just want to say
that what likely would occur is the
woman saying i'm breaking up with you
i'm leaving right women have a choice
and if the man is is too in one
direction then it just breaks apart so
maybe i actually say i should say i
agree with you that degree of
individualism would probably break down
yeah that's the extreme going too far
what i wanted to say though is that i
think the extreme of individualism would
be the man beating the woman geez god i
mean that's the extreme well he clearly
doesn't at that point cares so little
for her well-being he causes her harm
right
so
i'm thinking about like prenuptials do
you
as i guess through your psychology do
you think prenuptials are i feel like
prenuptials should be written into
marriage without even like the option
personally but what do you think about
those i don't have a prenup personally
so you know i mean i i think it's going
to be different for each person um but
no i mean i i just personally
view marriages as a as the kind of
commitment that you make without um
having without needing or wanting to
have like kind of a if we break up plan
because the plan is no matter what
happens we're not breaking up however um
i i am i'm an individualist and i
totally get that every marriage is
different and if other people say that
they just feel better with a prenup i
don't i don't have any problem with that
i i gotta say if you think you need a
prenup you should not get married yeah
don't don't but that's why i think they
should be written in without you having
to think about it no no no no i disagree
i disagree why would getting married to
someone mean that all of your wealth
from the last 40 years of my life would
would now be gone if she decided to
leave me that's insane because marriage
is till death do us part if you're
trying to date someone you don't need a
prenup and if you're pledging your life
to another person you shouldn't need one
and if you do maybe you should
reconsider thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you